- With my students, a lot
of them have not had a lot
of academic success.
They've faced a lot of obstacles.
(chiming)
That's what's great about Khan Academy is
they have success.
So I think that really builds them up.
They're all working on the same program,
but they're working on
very different things
and the great thing about that is,
there's no judgment.
(cheering)
They actually love Khan
Academy so much that they
approached me to start a club that was
specifically doing Khan Academy.
They're asking to do math work
outside of the regular school day,
like totally their own motivation.
These kids are creating social connections
and boosting their self esteem
and just feeling great about themselves
all through the connection
of doing Khan Academy.
(light music)